good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy hump day
it is thrilling is it exciting because
it is a jackson claude original recipe
back in the freaking freaking studio
back in the studio this week was so long
yet so short i feel like we were just
here i am we were just doing breaking
bread you look so different
what's different is it because you moat
and growed
excuse me you mode and growth
met and grat yeah yes i met and greeted
needed and greeted
it so i was going to get to that yeah it
was kind of i was like i actually woke
up and was like thinking of like a good
joke for the show today and that's what
i came up with that's going to be a good
episode really good okay i was going to
get to everything but i was just going
to say that we have breaking bread
tonight spotify live and like last we
spoke we were doing breaking bread and
we literally have not spoken since how
busy this weekend was for both of us i
got back from dallas last night i was in
town for the spritz meet and greet at
specs and you guys it was my first solo
meet and greet and like not only did i
kill it
but everyone who came was just so
amazing wonderful like i could have
spoken to everyone for so much longer
than i even did there were so many new
mamas
there were so many just
like people who have been around for so
long so many people brought wonderful
gifts it was really just
a pleasure it's a pleasure and i just
feel like everyone who is there like
we're just like so simpatico you know
there's like a vibe i feel like we all
right does that ever happen at a meet
and greet where it's like we were
electric we were all in this together
like we'll always have dallas it was
electric i know what you mean we'll
always have dallas you guys and if you
know you know if you were there like you
know no it looked amazing i was like
watching on instagram and the content
was premium the toasters were premium
and it looked like a extravagant affair
it really was i got to meet and greet so
many people signing autographs i had
never really sent an autograph before
but my fire penmanship came like this
was the role i was born to play you need
to write a book because like you you
sign your name so many times when you
write a book yeah and like if you don't
have a good signature like it's actually
embarrassing yeah um
and like you need to do that just so you
can really flex your penmanship yeah
because i was signing boxes and canvas
bags and it wasn't as much it wasn't the
best seamless yeah the
pen to paper
it wasn't perfection so yeah i would
love to do that like put my john hancock
over everything yeah i remember like
when i i literally practiced my
signature before my book came out and i
was like looking at i think it was
stassi she's such
a cool signature
but also her name like the s and the s
it's just not fair like i'm literally co
like they're just two ugly blocky round
letters you know well actually you could
make the c and o very similar and it
would look like s and s you know yeah i
guess but it's just like being like
people think being famous is so easy and
like it's literally so hard you know
that's like when people do logos like
like the netflix logo yeah it stands for
never pause can you believe that claudia
i don't think i've ever laughed so hard
at something you've ever made in my
whole life it only took what nine years
on the internet but thank you no but
before that it was something else yeah
but this made me laugh harder i think i
watched it 10 times and i laughed every
time no literally like can we just talk
about how like i'm really coming into my
own on tik tok did it go viral that one
no of course not but i also posted it i
couldn't sleep before my flight to
toronto it was literally like three in
the morning it's like the worst timing
um so it did fine it got like maybe like
150 views but like i could it could have
done that that's premium they got a
million views on reels because reals
people are real people
powerful words make it a camera pro jot
it down
reals people are real people
and we like good comedy jackie
that's beautiful thank you so much how
are we doing on tick tock since we last
spoke also i needed to let everyone know
at the meet and greet was a girl who's
been a toaster for three weeks because
she found us on tik tok
it's working
it's working that is what i love to hear
and she was so toasty i would have never
known she was so new that so it's
reaching the intended audience like are
you trying to make me cry like that's
literally what we set out to do and
we're doing it we're doing it oh that is
such a relief
oh
um well we've got a great show it's
wednesday so we have deer toasters we've
got to jump right in even though we've
been off for like six days no no i'm not
saying it's time to jump in i was just
giving everyone like a rundown of what
was going on is that okay yeah i'm gonna
call you out though every time there's a
lawyer in congress
uh yep yep every time there's a lull in
conversation between me and claudia she
says well we have a great show well you
wanna know why i won we do have a great
show
and two somebody's got to say something
no no like
conversation we never not have something
to say no but like when in the before
like the crunch and before the stories
and everything
sometimes there's like a dip and i
always think a great way to pick back up
because then we don't go into the
stories when i say that then we think of
something else to say you know sure but
i have so many other things i could have
said like how was your weekend i could
have talked about the rest of my weekend
how was ben on the toast yesterday it
was good obviously you didn't watch it
um no i didn't when i saw a notification
like i was so in a time warp this
weekend especially since i was supposed
to leave for dallas on thursday and due
to um the fact that
nothing works yeah i didn't get to go
until saturday yeah my flight on
thursday was cancelled all flights that
day were canceled because there was some
rain in the morning and then they blame
everything on weather the rest of the
day is beautiful at the destination it's
beautiful and it's like people have been
flying now for almost a century like you
really want to say you can't fly in the
weather no they blame it on rain they
say weather because that is like an
acceptable way to cancel and that way
they don't have to like reimburse you
for all of your trouble if they cancel
you for no reason then like you are
entitled to like a credit and all these
things from the airline but when they
say weather because there's a drop of
rain that's them like not having to pay
you it was so crazy it was
thunderstorming when i woke up but i
never even left my house my flight was
canceled i tried to get on any other
flight they wanted to route me through
pittsburgh and i just wasn't in the mood
for a divine diversion like i just
didn't see that for me you have to be in
the mood there was nothing divine about
it and also traveling with a baby like
we're not going to get no that's just
not going to happen so then i was like
you know what clearly there was some
rain today the airlines are [ __ ] up
we'll go friday booked a flight for
friday before i left the house it was
canceled every other flight from that
route was canceled i looked at every
other airport there was not a nary a
flight like
nothing works it was so crazy you olivia
and i all went to different airports on
the same morning to go to different
places
i
bought four tickets and thankfully one
of them took off and then i got a refund
for the other three olivia sat on the
plane for six hours until she was forced
to go home and you never even left your
house never even left my house because
48 hours because your flight was
canceled and all other flights were
cancelled it was a crazy travel weekend
i hope it was like
a moment in time no it's been getting
really bad since memorial day and then
the new york post like wrote up that day
and i would i thankfully they did
because i was like looking for other
travelers to talk to or like community
or like an article that's like delta
canceled 1500 flights today like so that
i knew it wasn't just like what's going
on there's no one to talk to there's no
community when your flight gets canceled
and it's like i guess if i was at the
airport i could commiserate with other
travelers yes i'd love to do that by the
way but i was just like i was looking on
twitter like delta canceled to see like
if other people were having the same
experience like what was going on
and
new york post wrote it up and they said
it was the worst travel day of the
summer
you guys the summer hasn't even started
it's true it's still technically spring
summer hasn't even started wait what did
summer start june 21st i think it
started yesterday oh so it still wasn't
summer out there so it wasn't summer
when they said it i think it's gonna be
really bad and continue to be bad
because like friday was a beautiful day
and your flight was canceled and all
flights were cancelled from that route
yeah so me and ben are trying to plan a
trip to italy in july and honestly part
of me like doesn't even want to go even
though i have to say flying back from
canada i got to use my global entry for
the first time
and i swear to god like i am elite i'm
better than everyone it felt so good
like it was it was worth the journey to
jfk in the middle of a wednesday and it
was worth all the trouble highly
recommend getting global entry and i'd
have to take my shoes off that is nice i
haven't
in general i don't have a desire for
travel
i'm not going anywhere ever you don't
want her to be lost i don't want her to
be lost but like for people who have to
travel like what do you do and it just
made me realize like what is something
that you absolutely have to go do that
like you couldn't just like i had to go
for the meet and greet like a funeral a
funeral like to say goodbye to a loved
one a wedding anything else if i was
going through that i would just cancel
my training it was like an optional
affair and really everything is optional
i just don't know how people are living
like this like
will i go on my trip who knows yeah no
it's um it's crazy so i'm so happy to be
home ben wanted to go visit olivia this
weekend and like i love olivia with
every fight like there is not my heart
is filled with love for my sister olivia
no one knows her husband no one doubts
it and michaela like horse i would take
a bullet
three but not a plane but not a plane
like so i'm like ben we can't go like my
mental health like i can't take it no
i can't it's really really bad no i know
so i'm glad our travel weekend is behind
us and we can be here to give everyone
the show that they deserve
yeah back to the show back to the show
but like is anyone else shook no it was
shook worthy but
it happened in a vacuum so if you
weren't traveling this weekend like you
don't give a [ __ ] you'll all see you'll
all see enjoy your trip to you and like
you'll just be looking for a community
and for people to talk to and for people
who are talking about it so this is for
the people who need to feel seen because
they didn't get to their place where
they were going on time
this is for all of you because i was
just like
i was it was shook okay at least you got
to experience the whole thing from your
house you weren't sitting at laguardia
airport for 12 hours
if i was
i don't even know then it would have
made the news i literally woke up at
eight flight was canceled the flight was
cancelled i'm like you know let me get
my ass to the airport i'll hop on and
you went without a flight i had by the
way that was something i couldn't miss i
had a workout i know i know i know i
went without a flight about three
tickets one of them took off canceled
the other two
loved that whole 24 hour cancellation
thing i got my money back immediately
did my event still haven't gotten my
money back for my friday i still haven't
gotten my money back from this delta i
haven't gotten my money back for my
friday flight that never took off and
there was never any other route i could
have taken you guys didn't even tell me
hey jump on this flight you guys just
said good luck also they never even sent
a notification that the flight was
canceled this was the craziest thing so
i woke up that morning i looked on
flightaware
and it said canceled and i was like what
i didn't get enough i have the app you
know they they let me know when
everything's happening so i went to my
app still says boarding on time i click
boarding on time and it says canceled oh
and so all morning i was also like
trying to get on the phone with delta to
confirm that it's cancelled tried to
call delta nine hour wait time uh okay
so i made it to toronto i was in toronto
for approximately four hours ran for my
event in full glam i'm sweating in the
back of this uber my flight's at 10 30.
i get to the airport literally 9 55.
bruce security i run he took my settings
but i said sir you can keep it i run get
to the gate five minutes before boarding
my phone starts buzzing i'm like oh it's
probably been checking on me your flight
has been canceled as i'm literally
standing at the gate we booked you on a
flight this was thursday they said we
booked you on a flight saturday 6 pm
thanks guys i'm like what
we called
not only did they say we have a long
wait time they said you can't get on the
line bye [ __ ] yeah they gave me like a
number to text instead and it was an
hour to get a text back it was so
psychotic and when you think about the
travel industry at a glance it's like we
are first of all travel is
so expensive like it's more expensive
than it's ever been and we are being
treated like
worse than we've ever been treated it's
a scam it's literally a scam that we're
all just okay with because like how else
are we gonna get there when you look
around the airport it's just full of
miserable people and i don't blame them
and it's like the people who you're able
to talk to like the gate agents like
they they can't do anything they didn't
cause this no and who can we talk to no
and really justice for the gate agents
because airlines are so
understaffed people are so miserable and
cranky and they take it on out on the
gate agent when the agent is just trying
to get through their shift and get home
of course and that's going to like
force the gate agent to seek different
employment of course that's why they're
going to travel and everyone is just
miserable yeah period and not even like
we're it's just so unhappy and
everything's so unpleasant you try to
take a vacation with your family to have
a nice weekend off you work hard and
can't even [ __ ] get there like
how are we supposed to get to a better
place it ain't right it ain't right
there's no accountability in the area
can who can we talk to and really we
need tpg to take up the mantle and fight
for us well you know what i was actually
watching this tick tock so i forget what
the date was but people on tick tock are
trying to organize a gas strike so for
like two days nobody buys gas um i think
they've done it in the past and it's
like it's
in
they're trying to seek the gas prices be
brought down because no one can afford
gas anymore
so um and people were like making fun of
the guy trying to start it but he's like
it actually works like 50 years ago and
like why don't we just try like two days
nobody buys gas i actually thought it
was kind of smart and i know people like
need to travel but we need to go on
strike i agree
but also the pilots are on strike too
yeah no and the delta is like begging
retired pilots to come back to work no
one wants it seems like nobody wants to
work these days yeah but because the
like they're overworked the pilots
they're underpaid but they also fired so
many employees in the aviation field who
didn't get vaccinated like maybe you
could bring those people back now too
and it's like who were the travelers
need to strike the pilots are striking i
think air traffic control is striking
that happened like in florida a few
weeks ago they said it was weather but
really everyone was on strike
who are we the t who are we striking
against i think the faa yeah yeah yeah i
don't know but like the secretary of
transportation there's someone who's in
charge here 100 and it's not us and it's
not us and we need tpg to really bring
everyone together he's gallivanting
around europe but when he comes back
this is his time yeah
this is his time this is his time okay
um so travel rant complete um
don't go anywhere unless you have to and
without further ado if you are traveling
and you're delayed and you need some
girls to get you through here we are
with the fast five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
the new starbucks bia energy drink with
caffeine naturally found in coffee fruit
it's energy that's good it's a beverage
that is crafted from caffeine naturally
found in coffee fruit as well as
antioxidant vitamin c it includes three
delicious fruity flavors mango guava
raspberry lime and pineapple passion
fruit and it is a refreshing
fruit flavored boost of feel good energy
in a way that only starbucks can deliver
the cans are 12 ounces 90 calories and
they contain 160 milligrams of caffeine
if you are not a coffee girl or you are
seeking out you know different sources
of caffeine check out the starbucks by
energy drink the mango guava is really
good
and the starbucks bio energy drink is
available online at grocery stores
convenience stores and gas stations
nationwide check it out we have them
here in the studio and it's just like a
delicious thing to wake up to today's
episode is also brought to you by legacy
box we were just talking about legacy
box the simplest and safest way to
digitize all of your aging video tapes
camcorder tapes film reels and pictures
so that they are preserved forever so
home movies can transport us back to
unforgettable times we haven't watched
ours in so many years we have hundreds
of vcrs and for a while we were like
trying to buy like things on bestbuy.com
to like adapt our vcr to a thumb drive
and then legacy box started sponsoring
our show a few years ago and our life
was forever changed
so here's how it works they send you the
kit it's easy and safe it includes
everything you need to safely pack and
send your recorded moments including
safety stickers for every item then they
professionally digitize them so each
item is hand digitized by a team of over
200 trained technicians in tennessee if
you've got it they can digitize it they
can digitize 19 different types of media
from vhs tapes to super 8 film they
preserve all your treasured moments
and when we got it back we got it back
on a thumb drive first of all like going
from that big box of crap to literally a
one-inch thumb drive was
just technology at its finest it was so
premium they sent us emails throughout
the way like here's an update on your
order i think it was like 12 total
emails it is such a nice gift to get for
someone like an anniversary or mother's
day father's day um
it's everything of the sort and even if
you use our code you don't need to send
your stuff in now but just like get the
kit use the code because it's limited
supplies and then send it in when you're
ready
visit legacybox.com
toast to take advantage of this limited
time offer for 40 off and you can
discover the magic of bringing your past
back into view take advantage of this
exclusive offer today but use your
legacy box whenever you're ready it's
legacybox.com toast to save 40 off
legacybox.com what was that oh yeah
toast
our first story is a big news of the day
probably the story i care most about
luke combs welcomed his first child with
his wife nicole hawking and they
revealed his name baby boy tex lawrence
combs entered the world on father's day
and they were kind enough to share name
photo everything with us and kylie take
notes and warm the cockles of our hearts
so i feel like the pressure for luke and
nico homes to have like the best country
name was really high because like
you know we've interviewed luke so many
times
um and he really and i think he knows
like he embodies he always says it's
like his songs are redneck imagery like
he embodies country culture and his
child's name like i don't even know if
he knows like the amount of pressure
like the suspense and he
passed with flying colors i hadn't
thought about what they would name their
son or what i expected them to name
their son plus luke and nicole have very
classic names yeah you know luke is like
one of the most popular boys lucas
twelve 1285. don't forget it be kind to
others
um
but yeah there is a lot of pressure to
have like a
a country a country kid yeah and i love
this name i love tex and also he's texan
luke texan i don't know he loves the
cowboys nobody loves caroline he's here
in north carolina because he went to
sorry cops loves the cowboys and they
bet on every game yeah no they're from
north carolina and i think nico's from
florida yeah
but
tex and then lawrence's classic name and
it's probably a family name gorgeous
love this name so happy for them like
this is really just like a
a country fairy tale it's a country
fairy tale i love them so much i was
like screaming
um you know being on nico's close
friends story like is amazing are you on
it yeah and so i think a lot of people
thought she already had the baby but she
was on the close friends being like nope
not yet and so i didn't think it was
coming so soon no i think it was
imminent and also i remember when she
post announced her when they announced
that they were pregnant they were like
coming spring
2022. and people were like to them
where's the baby like it's spring and
she was like no it's still spring i
think he literally came on june 21st
yeah exactly so happy for them wishing
them well
love them and this is beautiful jackie
that's beautiful that is beautiful and
the early days are just so special and
so chaotic and crazy this is so sweet so
sweet also the american academy of
pediatrics just put out new guidelines
for healthy baby sleep which everyone
was sending me yesterday like if you're
on like mom instagram like all of your
accounts are posting graphics today okay
and it's really just like obvious stuff
what does it say like baby should sleep
on his back baby shouldn't have anything
else in the crib but like this is now
they they said they're saying it
officially yeah you know no weighted
blankets swaddles or like
who the [ __ ] would put a weighted
blanket on a baby a weighted swaddle
might make them feel you know in theory
might make them feel like or crush them
toasty uh no incline more than 10 inches
in the crib like a pillow sort of thing
anyways so check that out even though
i'm sure you were all doing that already
i'm sure you've heard it all before
there was nothing that i was like oh
crap i've been doing it right right
right crap crap crap even though
sometimes i do check harry's camera and
i do see like you know a stuffed animal
no in the corner stuffed animal in the
corner of his crib yeah the lies no
there is there's not a stuffed animal
there's like some [ __ ] you know no
there's not not since he's been like
since he reached two months oh okay yeah
maybe it was like when he was born and
when he was born yeah they put stuffed
animals in the crib to make it like a
little cozier it was cute yeah sure uh
also
was gonna say
also was gonna say
take your time
i think it was gonna be good when i said
it we've got nowhere to be and no not to
get there actually we do have somewhere
to be we're recording an interview after
this i know and i need to pump in
between so okay sorry i think my thought
is just completely left it has to go by
the side of the road collateral oh got
it back
i have to stop cursing i curse so much
and i need to stop now
because i can't curse like this around
my son so now when i curse i need you to
call me out
okay that'll be hard for me just because
for me like the word [ __ ] is like the
word the you know like i don't even
notice it these days shoot
shoot fudge oh crap
oh crikey
so just call me out like i'll try really
like i've been saying for years but like
now i'm really working on it so i
totally respect that i'll do my best to
help you but like i am not gonna be that
mom like if my kids curse like i don't
give a [ __ ] like they could be doing
meth you know yeah no i need a swear jar
on the show okay fine and what we'll put
the money towards charity yeah
we'll find out we'll do a swear venmo
like who what are you gonna bring a
quarter to every show a swear bed no
that's cute yeah yeah
cool maybe we'll donate it to um you
know a cause that helps babies
in need oh love baby to baby baby to
baby love
our next story philanthropic queens like
that just took such a great turn no
ain't you know that's you know what that
is
turning a neggie into a posi
[Laughter]
our next story haley bieber is sued for
trademark infringement over road
skincare line
hayley bieber and her new beauty brand
are in hot water the model who launched
her road skincare line on june 15th is
being sued for trademark infringement by
an eight-year-old fashion brand of the
same name as first reported by tmz in a
statement to page six style the latter
rhodes legal team claims bieber tried to
acquire the trademark from a design duo
in 2018 when they refused she allegedly
went forward with launching her own
brand anyway they posted a statement to
their instagram um saying you know
they're very disheartened that haley
would do this
loser i think you should read the
statement i have like really harsh
thoughts on this
and i just want to say
i have bought a dress from shop road
that was in xl and i swear to god i
couldn't get it over my thigh so maybe
they should focus on that instead of
losery ass statements like this but
nevertheless i digress was that the
loser sneeze yeah literally what the
what's the movie i mean it's in
everything in the 90s you know when it's
from like a classic when he was like you
have been doing the loser sneeze since
loser
and who put them in their place oh
missy's brother of course yeah of course
he did okay here's the statement from
shop road nine years ago we quit our
jobs and founded road out of our
apartment creating a fashion company
from nothing where two women
entrepreneurs who met in college built
the road brand and put years of hard
work into our minority co-owned company
today we were forced to file a lawsuit
against haley beeper and her new
skincare line that launched last week
and that is using the brand road we
didn't want to file this lawsuit but we
had to in order to protect our business
we admire haley she has worked hard and
earned the ability to create her own
skincare line we don't want to sue haley
we want to celebrate her as fellow women
entrepreneurs we wish her every success
do you haley could choose any brand for
her skincare line we we have only the
brand name road that we've built that's
why we didn't sell her our brand when
she has four years ago and why we ask
her now to change her skincare lines
brand her using our brand is hurting our
company our employees our customers and
our partners okay i just want to say i
have been a customer and i'm not hurt by
this no and to be honest like this is
the best thing that could happen to
their company because now they put out
the statements right everyone's reading
it i personally had never heard of
shoproad and by the way they're fancy
they sell at sacks their dresses are
expensive yeah i bought a dress that was
literally expensive and i was like first
of all it didn't fit and second of all
it was like so like not
made well
so maybe i'm just biased because oh yeah
it's cute stuff and now they have and
now i'm seeing stuff i wouldn't have
seen maybe i'll check out their brand i
have so many things thanks haley the
first thing is that
it's not like the way that this set uh
statement makes it seem it's like haley
saw the company road thought it was a
cool word and stole it it's literally
her name first of all so it's like it's
not like she had it was their creative
idea that she stole like literally she
was born with this name first of all
second of all they say when she tried to
buy our company four years ago now i
don't know this for a fact but i would
literally bet uh my entire life that she
didn't want to buy their clothing
company she probably wanted to buy like
shoproad.com or the at username people
buy usernames all the time i've bought
usernames we bought the spritz username
like
so
i think it's intentionally misleading
like she's been watching us she wanted
to buy her whole company and then she
decided to do it better i think the
wording there is very intentionally
misleading
and two um
first of all one is a skincare brand
one is a clothing brand so there's no
way anyone is going to confuse oh no i
bought the serum from shop road when i
thought it was road hayley bieber like
literally you can't even buy one similar
product does road sell chapstick like
it's so stupid first of all
second of all uh things are allowed to
have the same name legally in this
country if they're different brands yeah
that's the thing for me with all of
these cases and i do feel like this one
is the biggest reach of them all because
you know the last one was this cookin
and it was the facial service but they
were all skincare based so i think
everyone in a court of law might have
ground to stand on lori harvey the
facialist okay the facialist first came
i actually don't think she had ground to
santa because kim wouldn't have been
able to trademark it in her field if she
had ground to stand on and she would
have gone with a different name but it
is a little similar so
they're all in skincare so there's a
conversation to be had sure sure but is
everyone is anyone talking about how
like delta airlines there's also like a
faucet company named delta right
magnolia bakery magnolia uh right that's
what
gains and when these things happen i
really defer to the trademark office
because if it was a conflict you
wouldn't be able to trademark it so if
haley and i don't think hayley bieber
would launch a brand that she couldn't
have trademarked that's like the first
thing you do in business so she's able
to trademark her products with ease then
she's not violating any laws i think
this lawsuit is a complete waste of
their time and money and this whole
thing is thirsty and losers fees and i'm
getting tired of it no this thing this
is like such a reach like my arm is
killing me yeah um and i felt like their
statement was so like victim mentality
and i think it was full of lies like i
don't and i don't know for this for a
fact but i would just bet anything that
haley bieber did not try and buy their
clothing company four years ago i think
they their wording was intentionally
confusing because i do think she
probably tried to buy some of the
website donate domains or something else
like i don't think she was out here
buying clothing companies yeah
so i just feel like this is like
like people are seeing like
even we were talking about before i had
no idea laurie harvey had a um
skincare line and lori harvey never even
posted anything it was other people
pointing out skin by lh versus skin by
kim um and it was great press for
her i thought her website was gorgeous
like i'd never heard of it now i'm like
maybe i need to get something right so i
think this is like a trend people are
seeing and like if they position
themselves as the victim against a big
bad celebrity they're gonna get tons of
press tons of sales tons of attention
they are getting those things but i
think it's also like the discourse i've
seen around this particular story is not
similar to the ones i've seen about like
kim
and skin by lh why do you think that is
because people are seeing this and it's
a reach it's not the same
category not even close so it has
literally i can think of a million
thrive cosmetics thrive market
i could think of a thousand companies in
this country that are in different
sectors that
literally swift trucking taylor swift
like i could think of a thousand
cross
yes category brands that have this
similar or same or even just one word
right and at least this is her name
it's just this is such a reach and it's
it's giving like like
loser energy sorry i don't want to be
mean but like i just feel like this is
like taking advantage of like a movement
right when you really don't have a leg
to stand on and
like most things it started in earnest
yeah and now people are really
just reaching here like i was reading
the comments on uh actually they were
they were actually extreme a lot of our
toasters are like extremely smart legal
girlies and so people were just having
conversations in our facebook group
about i also want to read the comments
on the post yeah i'm sure it's like
stay strong
right but um hold on let me find it
because i thought it was very
astute you know smart girlies doing
their legal tang
let's see let's see road right here oh
my god literally stay strong okay oh man
are people saying stay strong yeah yeah
um
okay
okay some people are saying they're
signing with the business some people
said this is definitely a pr move it's
not illegal to use the same name in
different industries they probably asked
four years ago to avoid this exact same
thing not to steal her name right um a
lot of people said she also didn't ask
if she could use their name she asked if
she could buy their name probably for
domain purposes not for trademarking um
someone else said haley is not going to
change the name nor should she really as
i gather wrote as a clothing brand is
trademarked as it is a clothing brand if
they were working in skincare this would
be a different story haley using the
name in a completely different space and
market isn't wrong of her also her team
asking to buy the name four years ago
isn't that odd it would have been odd if
they hadn't reached out in hopes of
buying the name if anything i would
imagine this would be a would be
positive for their brand not causing
them any harm
someone else i basically live in
trademarks for my job i thought i'd
share what actually exists and what is
currently live and active this is
haley's trend trademark filing i will
attach the other two
for the same names hers is filed first
out of all three
that's interesting um and of the other
two uh are claiming both clothing and
retail so haley did it first and it's in
a different category also none of them
were filed even close to four years ago
like this company is claiming i feel
like it's easy for people to pretend to
be mad with celebrities for made-up
reasons with no substance and this is
what it feels like and she has
screenshots so that's actually really
interesting haley's um road skin care
was trademarked before any of the others
and um they're in different categories
which is really what this whole
conversation is about oh well that's
that on that then yeah i just don't like
um like people using like a movement to
like of course it's like it's weird to
get it doesn't feel genuine i don't
think i'm pr victim pr especially when i
literally know for a fact this hasn't
affected their business one ounce no
it's the complete opposite i personally
never heard of shop road these are nice
stresses i'll check them out yes so it's
like haley and they know haley's hurting
our employees our customers our partners
drama
haley's hurting your customers no we're
fine we are literally fine haley's
hurting their customers yeah it's it's
crazy but this is like a trend now and
at first it was like crazy and now i'm
like all right no it's just it needs to
be called out yeah and that's that yeah
on that on that
more fashion news from your fashion
girlies from your fascists
that's a joke from france i was gonna
say more fashion news from your fashion
girl if you wear the same thing every
day and keep matching more fashion
girlies from your maxinistas yeah from
shop amazon yeah from missy empire has
anybody heard of this website missy
empire i saw an instagram ad from a girl
that i follow and she was wearing a set
collared and shorts and that's all i've
been wearing obviously and
i colored and shirts are all that fits
me right now no collared shirts and
shorts are all that fits me right now
and they look nice and and proper and
professional and so i was influenced by
her and i went to missy empire and it
looks just like misguided though like
the whole website and it's missing
misguided at google to see if they're
related i didn't find anything no but
those instagram ads are getting better
it used to be like a scam if you ever in
your life you know it was a girl it was
an influencer a grand deal well if you
ever in your life like see an ad for a
website called z crave don't buy their
ski don't buy it first of all they don't
let you return don't buy this so
expensive that was the biggest scam i'd
ever in my life and it made me so wary
of ins that was facebook actually
yeah snitch and i once got matching like
cool ski suits from one of those
websites and it was like hers was pink
and mine was bl mine was pink and hers
was blue and it was like furry and we
looked we would have been like two snow
buddies on the slopes couldn't have been
cuter yeah they might as well have sent
a hot bag of garbage
because it was
crack crap yeah you have to be so
careful these days
you uh we would have been so cute i know
okay our fashion news harry styles and
gucci are teaming up for a playful 1970s
inspired collection called hahaha
collection and it's inspired by harry's
friendship with the bran brands with the
brienne of tarth
with the brand's creative director
alessandro michelle oh so h a
hey
h oh harry analysis i didn't understand
the ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
ha ha ha ha ha ha collection either i was
like is it funny are you comic um this
is cute honestly i don't know if like
harry's fans are out here buying gucci
suits because i think they're really
young but for harry's brand this is
great um the stuff looks cute he's so
like
he's so fashion he's so fashion and a
fellow fascist
even though his fans aren't you know
probably trying to buy these men's suits
he is like an icon in the fashion world
and this is really like good for his
brand
and he's gucci and gucci is him and it's
perfect and he's not like 70s 70s
patterned suits it's a no-brainer yeah i
think this is really smart um
and it just makes me think about like
celebrity collabs with like major
fashion houses remember ariana grande
for
uh
what was it jumanji yeah that was like
random what did she do for that what was
the collection what did they do for her
i don't remember i don't know her
obviously there's kim and balenciaga
which i can visualize what that looks
like you know long leggings over your
feet and gloves and the bags yeah and
the bags so i don't really um
i like that ariana grande collab was
weird but what's different is like those
were like i'm we're going to be the face
of this brand this is a collaboration
collection yes yes yes that's true um
also the brand said the phrase hahaha is
how much uh alessandra michelle and
harry have ended their messages to each
other for years since uh meeting
i just feel like that's like a little
personal no so that's why it's called
that but it's also like harry it's their
initials sandro
it's their initials yeah this stuff is
really cute harry styles is like really
killing it like i know with the music
with his personal life he seems happy
his nail polish uh company is like doing
so well pleasing um like harry is is
that [ __ ] like he's really
like kind of like the biggest rock star
in the world no for real the way like
and what's nice about it is that he
really is worthy and he's so talented
you know it's not like everybody's just
obsessed with someone who stinks no and
it's like this not that they stink but
it's like it's not confusing like
and this is not me railing on bts but
like when you when they first came on
the scene we were like confused like how
are there literally a million people at
a stadium and now i understand it but
with harry it's like we've watched his
progress and honestly now that i've
known bts for a few years i can say they
are extremely worthy oh by the way we
never made a story you know they're
going on hiatus i did see that is it
crazy it is crazy but you know me
holding out hope as always no but hiatus
and i just don't think like
even though this is gonna hurt me to say
like
little mix is not bts like i don't i
guess they're like the beatles you know
yes and
all good things must come to an end
because i was gonna say how do you walk
away from that but like people do it
every day no i know and i wanted to get
your take on something me and ben were
arguing about yesterday you know marcus
mumford is leaving mumford and sons he's
going solo okay and me and ben were
going back and forth on like whether he
would be successful or not and ben like
didn't even know his first name and ben
was like this is the worst idea ever
he's going to flop and i'm like i think
he's going to be huge
i think it's going to be the same like
why can't he just like go solo and bring
the rest of the band with him isn't it
him singing anyway it's literally
mumford and sons like they could just
call mumford no i know and um why does
things have to be this way why does
everything have to be so extreme but the
band had already started falling apart
like last year one of the
one of the band members left um
so i feel like it was only a matter of
time but like how do you perceive
mumford and sounds like me and ben were
on two different pages i said like
they're not at the same level but they
remind me similarly to like coldplay
that's what i thought you were going to
say agreed just like i thought i was
crazy for saying that they're just such
a well-respected band they're not like
the thirstiest but like they draw huge
crowds thank you oh my god i feel so
validated ben thought i was crazy i'm
like they literally play stadiums i went
to one of their concerts it was like in
college it was literally the biggest
place i've ever been sure it was an
amazing show it was incredible i used to
be such crab including as crazy about
mumford and sons as you would think and
this is how you know the power of
mumford you would think that we wouldn't
like them because they're so they're not
us they're not scenic no they're
alternative yet they are for everyone
okay i'm so glad you agree i feel so
validated because i'm like am i crazy or
like i literally the clips i see like on
social media from some of their concerts
they don't go on tour a lot but when i
do it's like
hundreds of thousands of people
okay i feel so validated thank you yeah
and by the way you know marcus mumford
wrote the theme song for ted lasso it's
his song yes yes yeah and it's really
good so he's been doing like his own
thing him and carrie mulligan
are they together married yeah i was
trying to think who he's married to
because i remember to someone famous
which is so exciting no and then ben was
like who's karen mulligan and that's
when i knew i couldn't talk to him
anymore it can be frustrating karen
mulligan okay
[Laughter]
okay are you ready for our next story no
okay good because thank you is it hot in
here today um
yeah it's been like freezing in here
every day so we come in our shorts for
the summer and now i'm sweating
today's episode is brought to you by
thuma
thuma practices an intentional less is
more design philosophy for the bedroom
with clean lines subtle curves and
lifestyle enhancing details thuma
provides that simplicity is the truest
form of sophistication introducing the
bed by thuma handcrafted from
eco-friendly high quality upcycled wood
you'll find beautiful unique variations
in the natural grain the minimalist
design featuring japanese joinery helps
elevate any space it's super supportive
for your mattress breathable and it's
made to naturally minimize noise and
create space it's made for how you live
the bed by thuma is backed with a
lifetime warranty it ships right to your
door in three easy to maneuver boxes and
it takes about five minutes to assemble
with no tools required along with the
bed by thuma thuma also offers other
bedroom essentials to elevate bedtime
the nightstand the side table and the
tray are perfect compliments to the bed
sumo works with one tree planted to
plant one tree for every bed and
nightstand sold all of their essentials
are green guard gold certified create
that feeling of checking into your
favorite boutique hotel suite but at
home with the bed by thuma now go to
thuma dot co co slash toast to receive a
25 credit towards your purchase of the
bed plus free shipping in the
continental us go to
co
thuma.coco
toast that's t h u m a dot c o slash
toast for 25 dollar credit why are you
laughing
zuma
zuma
zuma
let me be your zuma zuma
i'm glad i feel i feel complete and i
just couldn't move on until i got that
out yeah you should have said it
whatever said i tried but trust me there
was no window by the way so in this ad i
thought they were literally talking
about me
clean lines subtle curves and lifestyle
enhancing details
like to you am i buying for sale
the answer is yes yes i can be bothered
she can be
our next story garcelle bouvier is
opening up about her ongoing eczema
battle she said i wanted to crawl out of
my skin so garcelle is sitting down with
people magazine to talk about her
struggle with the painful skin condition
of eczema
so um i saw this yesterday on social
media it was like a digital cover it was
a beautiful picture of garcelle
literally my queen
um because i am going to rail on her so
i just want to say like i
love this
stan respect like i she's turning out to
be one of my favorite housewives in
history so before
so it was this digital cover and it was
like you know people is always like
breaking news about you know my life
with some and it said garcelle bouvet
opening up about my life with
eczema
and i was like
oh
um
okay
because like eczema is extremely common
i had it when i was a kid like it's
extremely common it affects more than 31
million americans right and it's just
like it's i didn't know it was something
that you had like an article written
about right yeah yeah that you have to
and i'm not you know doubting her
journey or her trauma but it's this this
is just like classic celeb like
you need when you get pressed as a
celebrity like you need like a something
a hook and like this is just kind of
like a like a light hook
extremely light hook i think that's a
kind way of putting it right um i don't
know why she even like needs extra press
she gets so much just from like
show her like the real i would just want
to hear garcelle talk about my life as
garcelle no so
that's a cover i would
and i was just like really confused by
this because to me having eczema is like
definitely an inconvenience but it's not
like a life-altering thing unless you
have like the worst case of eczema ever
and it's all over your face for the most
part people who struggle with eczema get
like especially in the winter like
patches on their legs and arms yes she
said she started getting patches behind
her knees right so it's definitely
inconvenient to me like the equivalent
is like
having to wear contact lenses like
there's something slightly off but it
doesn't change your life so this to me i
was like garcelle bouvier my life with
glasses like
it just it seemed like a lot i was
confused yeah
yeah but literally love respect the [ __ ]
out of garcelle i was just like
but i also i did see a tick tock about
garcelle um it was gmnn
garcelle's mindless news
thank you i was looking for like the
perfect way to wrap it up and you just
did it yeah um i did see this tick tock
of garcelle um like no one putting
enough respect on garcelle's name for
being like the absolute 90s style icon
if you go and look at her red carpet
photos from the 90s when she was like up
and coming she wasn't coming to america
like she's literally like everyone's
always posting like you know
uh
johnny depp and winoda like she's that
[ __ ] like
her little glasses and her like maxi
bodycon dresses like she's so sickening
i'm on my way here i am and just like
look up like a 90s red carpet 90s that's
all you need yeah everything of the sort
like she's like a tumblr account like
it's so sickening that's what she should
have done a uh interview on yeah my
life as a 90s fashion icon yeah that's
extremely interesting to me yeah wow
take a trip down memory lane on google
you guys like you will die because
garcelle obviously we know her now she's
like very glamorous
but she was like doing like the perfect
understate understated 90s glam like a
little makeup little glasses little
purse a little choker a little dress
yeah it was kind of everything
absolutely okay i'll go down a rabbit
hole at a later date if you're making
like a 90s mood board
make sure to include garcia our fifth
and final story are you ready for it
is it um
it the final story
[Music]
it's the final story
she wants her dinner
people are gonna be like they really are
fascists
[Music]
oh my god i was laughing i didn't watch
yesterday's episode but i did watch the
instagram reel i know exactly are you
gonna say hrh
oh oh i got so many comments on my tic
tac like in my laguardia rant oh my god
when i was ever telling everyone like
you're so dumb you're so stupid there
everyone's like you literally are giving
hrh vibes
and when i was saying it i was like am i
hrh i was like you're [ __ ] dumb like
i i felt so much like her i thought
that's what you were gonna say no i was
gonna say when you started imitating
people about the restaurants what did
you say i was like um well they have
such a restaurant yeah like no that's
what everyone says i was at the wedding
talking to people and like my friend
beatrice she literally sent me the
ticket she was like smell me i'm like
yeah cause she was like there's an h h
bagels
i'm like who [ __ ] cares
no and you're right i don't want to
lounge at the airport i just want to get
to where i'm going and then people are
like well it's so nice that they made it
so big and nice because if you're
delayed like you have somewhere to go
well why don't you work on not making it
delayed and stop building bagel shops
work on the delays not the place where
we are going to experience
delays
it doesn't have to be like this you guys
it wasn't always like this it wasn't
don't stand for it don't
airline strike
we're starting it yeah why not us we're
number two on spotify
why not us can we talk about that we're
still number two you sent it to me on
sunday us and joe us and joe like
literally the top podcasters on the
planet and we're still number two i know
because breaking bread is literally like
breaking the charts
that's what it should be called that was
and we have another one tonight you guys
we do so here are the deets in case you
missed it last time if you want to join
and listen live and be able to interact
with us
you don't have to interact but if you
want to listen live and like watch the
live chat it pops off it was crazy
download the spotify live app it's
really easy to download and then just
follow breaking bread and you'll get
notified when we go live which is 7 p.m
eastern time every wednesday if you're
busy at 7 pm eastern time or you're not
interested in the live experience you
just want to listen on your own leisure
it will be on the spotify app in due
time at so at um on friday on friday but
also if you have the spotify app you can
listen live right at 7 pm to breaking
bread the regular spotify app you just
can't like chat and stuff so if you're
going to tune in live just tune in on
the spotify live app it's free to
to know download our first and final
story brad pitt is on the cover of gq
talking about his acting career he said
he considers himself on his last leg he
said this last semester or trimester
what is the section going to be and how
do i want to design that that's kind of
crazy he is 58 so
i guess if we're going in tries
i mean this would be the third trimester
it's like low-key dramatic um yeah what
is with everyone today in the drama yeah
our customers
my eczema
my last i'm dying my last act at 58. no
this is like saying like like does he
have an illness it sounds like he's on
his way out yeah this is a quote that
will speak to you i'm one of those
creatures that speaks through art
i just always want to make
if i'm not making sure you used to go to
the bathroom
who was it
i think it was like kristin our friend
who said like one of her ics is like
when someone says they have to make or
like about a dog having to go to the
bathroom ew who the [ __ ] says that you
say that to kids like like you have to
make that like not we're adults you have
to go to the bathroom take a dump or
even make a duty piss like you have to
make yeah it's a great and that's what
it sounds like so i just want to always
make if i'm not making i'm dying in some
way honestly um now that just makes me
think of like brad pitt sweating crying
screaming for help on the toilet yeah
cause he's making um i think this is
hella dramatic i do wonder what he will
do next but um
i don't care because he's like so
handsome that he could literally work
until he's 100. yeah he also said that
he's quit cigarettes oh that's
interesting yeah cigarettes are like so
big in hollywood people don't talk about
that a lot yeah and so is vaping
especially for some people who have quit
i wonder if he's vaping i wonder if he's
vaping too but um i just feel like when
we were kids like in tabloids like
the nicole richie paris lindsey are like
they were always smoking cigarettes yeah
and now it's like taboo so we think that
they don't do it anymore they just don't
do it in public like whenever i've been
around celebrities they're literally
chain-smoking cigarettes that's so
interesting yeah and you know what it
makes me think of um
when the real housewives of beverly
hills went to dubai and like
literally lisa vanderpump finally got
called down jake went back to her room
with ken crying she started chain
smoking cigarettes and it's like she
probably does smoke cigarettes but we've
never seen it on the show yeah i think
it's like now how a lot of reality stars
vape and hide it yes but in the early
days of vanderpump roles they were chain
smoking outside yeah yeah yeah yeah so
it's like a dick diana she had a
cigarette in her mouth and it's funny
how like everyone hides smoking
cigarettes or even vaping
but they don't hide smoking weed
yeah well because i think like you know
one could argue the
list of benefits from smoking weed and i
don't think there's literally one
benefit from ripping a cigarette or a
vape looking cool
forgot about that
so true
so those are the past time stories brad
pitt has quit cigarettes
how cool is she oh my god i'm so cool if
you've seen the not like other girls
tour none of this is a surprise to you
and if you haven't seen it i do feel
sorry for you but i won't in a few weeks
and that's me being subtle
we love settlement let's leave it at
that i know you're dying no i was gonna
leave it at that you're keep going oh
sorry
anyways be cool smoking
just kidding i'm kidding no today's okay
let me i feel like i have to say this
now everything you've heard here today
uh is a joke we are not fascists we
don't think smoking cigarettes is cool
kind of um
and eczema is a big deal
should we continue on to dear toasters
our weekly advice segment that we do
every wednesday yeah we should are you
sure
i just like really need to pump we have
so much to do i thought maybe we could
like do deer tonight we have time
to let me i'll make it quick okay okay
sorry guys i i'm sorry no like we're
actually both filming day in the life
vlogs claudia competing day in the
lifetime so you'll see how like just you
know frantic i am today dear toasters is
brought to you by third love third
love's 24 7 classic t-shirt bra is
designed to fit and form to your body
every detail has been made with your
comfort in mind from fit to style to
function and beyond it forms to your
body to make your boobs look their best
plus the straps won't slip and there's
no pinching or digging they've literally
invented half cup sizes so you always
get the right fit it comes in sizes a
through h and they're exclusive half cup
sizes if you shout out to my age girls i
mean i'm an f girl it is it is it an f
brah
no
okay but actually like i didn't really
know what size bry was until third love
started sponsoring the show like four
years ago and i took that quiz and i was
like what and i swear to god it has
changed my life their quiz will change
your life the t-shirt bra is everything
of the sort no overflow no digging
straps like you're just wearing the
right size bra and i feel like half the
women in this country wear the wrong
size bra
um your bra size can change over six
times throughout your life so you should
always be getting a check they make it
easy to find a bra on third love that
actually fits with their fitting room
quiz it's like a personal shopper but
better it focuses on size breast shape
fit issues um and feeling is believing
give yourself the 24 7 comfort bra that
you deserve upgrade your bra today and
get 20 off your first order at
thirdlove.com
toast that's 20 off at thirdlove.com
toast thank you all right dear toasters
our advice segment if you ever want to
write in um you're having any trouble
you know at home with your relationship
with your friends with your boss dear
toasters gmail.com hey girly girls i'm a
huge fan and i love you both so much p.s
jackie i just had a baby boy two weeks
after you and i've been on this crazy
motherhood journey right along with you
sis thank you oh man you're welcome i'm
so curious to hear what you have to say
and now thinking of it through the lens
of a new mama i got you thank you for
like the pertinent context extremely now
on to my dilemma my parents my husband's
parents have been happily married for
almost 30 years and they live out of
town recently my father-in-law came to
visit my husband and i by himself for a
father-son golf outing on our way home
from dinner that evening i was seated in
the back seat behind my father-in-law
while my husband was driving without
intending to i looked up and oversaw my
father-in-law's phone screen while he
was texting i saw a message from him
saying we had just left dinner and he
wanted her for dessert along with other
messages that said something about
kissing i immediately looked away and my
first thought was how sweet that he
still sends flirty text messages to his
wife but then something in in me made me
look at his phone again and that's when
i saw the name at the top of the text
thread was not his wife then to solidify
the pit i was feeling when we got home
he announced that he hadn't heard from
his wife all evening and she must have
fallen asleep then he appeared to be
texting on our couch for the rest of the
night what would you do with this
information do i tell my husband what i
saw or do i continue to mind my own damn
business and not worry about it please
help a toaster with a pit
this is so tough this is so tough
because you don't want to be like a
snitch and you do want to mind your own
business but like how can you even keep
this like from your husband even if you
both decide not to do anything of it
about it like
wouldn't he want to know just even if
you're just gonna like
be shook together yeah but then also
like you're a woman who supports other
women like would you want to know 30
years later he wants someone else for
dessert like have her
no
um i would say to dump this burden on
your husband and let him decide what to
do with it yeah it's his parents no but
like they've been together 30 years his
whole life is and he just had a new baby
and like he's gonna his whole premise is
going to be off if he finds out that
well he'll have to grow up he's about to
be a father i don't know he is he is a
father i think you just swallow it and
let these people let the chips fall
where they may it feels wrong and like
what if down the line something happens
and like your husband says like you you
didn't tell me like he wanted i don't
think you'll ever regret telling him but
i do think you might regret not telling
him just your husband
yeah it would be really hard to not tell
your husband and like to one to keep
something from him but also like
something so big and
no and then it's like someone else's lie
becomes your lie and like now you're
becoming
implicated in this web of lies
dump it on him it's his parents it's not
your [ __ ] problem
well you were done snooping just kidding
no no i'm kidding i'm kidding uh yeah if
you can't live with it keeping it to
yourself no if you can't die with it
yeah then you got to tell someone yeah
and you could tell your husband and make
it his problem and ruin his life yeah
rooney everything he thought to be good
and true in this world but at least
you'll feel good yeah yeah no this is
about you you just had a baby keeping
the secret
is like in a lot of ways very selfless
yes
but also i just i don't think anyone
really ever regrets telling the truth
like of course not that's like the real
lesson
but also no good deed goes unpunished
so these are conflicting ideas there's
also the route you could take like
directly directly to your father-in-law
but like that's extremely crazy
that's extremely brave not your job
so here it is you have two
paths which one sounds more appealing to
you what kind of person are you can you
live can you die with it do you want to
do you think your husband could handle
it does he think his parents
relationship is perfect and this will
literally send him into a midlife crisis
right that's the thing like what is his
perception of his parents because like
some people especially those elite few
whose parents have been married for 30
years like put their parents on a
pedestal maybe he like puts his dad on a
pedestal so if this actually would like
shake the foundation
of the earth in which he walks like you
might want to second-guess telling him
but if he's like a rational human being
who's like oh it's nice my parents are
still married i wonder how they do it
then i think he might be able to take it
right right some people especially like
the older you get you think you get more
mature but the older you get and the
older like you're the longer your
parents have been married like it gives
you like a superiority complex yeah so
what kind of man is your husband that's
on you to decide but either keep it to
yourself or just tell your husband
depending on all of these things good
good luck to you girl best wishes best
wishes hey girlies long time listener
first time caller my son has become
really good friends with a kid named
maverick and they've been hanging out
all summer break your son sounds awesome
awesome so does your son's friend
i really like maverick and i've always
treat my kids friends to dinner ice
cream etc if they're in my home recently
whenever my son goes to mavericks he's
been asking me for money because
maverick's parents don't treat
personally i would be mortified as a
parent to ask a 12 year old for money
but i just let it go the other day while
picking up my son i got to talking to
maverick's mother and she asked me about
some money my son owed her i thought
this was incredibly weird but i just
promised to venmo her do you guys think
it's weird should i say something to her
because i pay for her son please help
sincerely a confused toaster that's so
weird i mean this isn't something i've
experienced yet
so but just the idea of a grown woman
saying your son owes me money
is really weird yeah and so
it does just make me
this there's always a difference between
cheap between being cheap and being poor
and i'm not sure which scenario this is
but if she's like a mom and she's busy
and she needs some money like part of me
is like just give her the money um but
then like the petty part of me is like
okay well you also have to start
venmo'ing her i think the concept of
asking the kid for money
is very weird but asking like later on
in the week like for the mom to
reimburse is less weird yeah but it's
framing it as your kid owes me money
numbers bizarre i took the kids to get
ice cream like it was this much
no this is really weird but like you
really never know what like someone's
financial situation is like of course
like you know for someone like you who
sounds financially stable enough to
treat the kids you think this is crazy
but it's like someone's in a different
scenario than you
but you don't have to be going off for
ice cream they could just play like in
the house right it cost zero dollars to
ride a bike right
and that snacks at home and snacks at
home yeah
this is so uncomfortable and honestly i
have not one piece of advice i don't
know i literally don't know how to
navigate this maybe some fellow mamas
could share in the youtube comments
what's typically done here because it's
not something i've ever thought about
because you know what if the situation
is like we're not going to pay for our
kids friends then fine no one's paying
and then we'll all reimburse each other
later on but then it's this it goes
against this woman's principles test of
12 year old for money she wouldn't be
asking the 12 year old she'd be asking
the mom like when when she came to pick
up her son got it
but it can't be one way it can't be i'm
paying for your kid and i'm paying for
my kid too yeah
yeah i think people with kids need to
weigh in and lead it lead the way
me neither so good luck i'm sorry i have
what's done this is hot like i'm
literally horrifying i have nothing to
add no me neither this is our third and
final one okay hey claudia and jackie
just want to start off by saying
congratulations on the new bebe claudia
congratulations on your second tour i
saw you in chicago and you were the
highlight of my trip
now let's get into it to give you a
brief background on my situation i'm 32
years old and i just broke up with my
boyfriend of three years i was
heartbroken to say the least
but because of that i moved out of our
place together and now i'm temporarily
living at home with my mom since being
home whenever i need help with some
things around the house that require
some heavy lifting i always call my
neighbor to see if he can help his name
is maverick
he's such a popular boy name and i just
want to say you guys we're not changing
these names people are writing in
exclusively using that so she calls her
neighbor maverick to help her out okay i
love it hallmark movie
maverick who i married who i literally
used to babysit as a kid grew up to be
the hottest man of course he didn't
uh we've recently started exchanging
some flirty dms back and forth and let's
just say there's a lot of sexual tension
there okay the only issue is he's 23 and
i'm 32 and my question for you is do i
just go for it a part of me thinks that
hooking up with his old babysitter would
be his wet dream but another part of me
is like what the [ __ ] am i doing these
people have been my neighbors for 30
plus years so i don't want to get into
anything awkward but at the same time
i'm kind of in a i don't give a [ __ ]
mood right now please help signed a
slightly cougary toaster i read this
book last night okay first of all really
recommend a part of your world okay um
and she's 37 and he's 28 and like at
first she can't get over it because it's
like so disgusting but then like it
really doesn't matter yeah but also 37
28 is different a 28 year old male is
very different from a 23 year old male
those five years are critical yeah and
as much as i i'm usually like throw
caution to the wind like just [ __ ] do
it 23 is like a little young and
that plus like you need the help around
the house like you don't want to make it
and like this is the 30-year neighborly
friendship like
is it worth
all the benefit losing those benefits if
things get awkward yeah i'm thinking no
i'm thinking even though i'm always like
i just [ __ ] i know people are going
to be like just do it yolo you know
caution to the wind and you're in this
season of your life but like
there's a handyman is really hard to
come by no and there are like 25 year
olds who don't live next door to you
yeah like if you're feeling cougary that
i'm like yeah [ __ ] do it if not now
because he's 23 it's because like you
have no intention of anything serious
with him and like
you need his help no but it's also a
little because he's 23. like it's just a
little too if he were older i'd be like
well get married he's 25. something
about 23 is like a little too close to
college yeah
yeah i see no potential for a
relationship because he's so young i was
ready for this to be like the hallmark
movie the happy ending end of your story
but i'm gonna say no
i'm gonna say no i think you'll regret
doing it you actually might regret also
not doing it but just if you're looking
to go [ __ ] someone else who's like young
go go love that journey for you i'm sure
there's an app for that yeah
cougarlicious.com you should amend it
honorable
um all right well that's our show that
was dear toasters thank you to everyone
who was extremely vulnerable with us um
the email to write in is dear toasters
gmail.com try and keep it as brief as
possible because a lot of the ones we
get are just like a little too long like
this is only an hour-long show but we do
live deer toasters on breaking bread so
we're able to get more context what kind
of
man is your husband does he think his
parents are infallible or can he handle
reality we would get to know them we
could give you better advice so if you
are joining the live show tonight and
you need some advice start thinking
about what you might want to ask us keep
in mind it is honest anonymous that's
the difference so if you want to talk
about like your mother-in-law or
something like she might hear it so just
letting you know it's the number two
podcast so she really might no actually
sorry she will know yeah
that's our show thank you so much for
listening to the morning toast of the
millennial morning show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as podcasts anywhere
podcasts can be found so that's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i already
know casbox all the places so wherever
you listen to podcasts find out some
morning toast and leave a five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are thank you guys so much for
an amazing hump day show and we'll see
you tomorrow for thursday goodbye